hello and welcome to this video playing
us thus first us from something
okay so king's indian arun felt a guru
thoughts okay
yeah i'm currently studying this a
little bit for white don't save what he
does against bishop i for the castling
is best now
and here we should be six best believe
see five is also playable okay remember
how the theory went 395 think whenever
he is actually completely incorrect I
mean people have played that I mean
strong players but I just don't think
it's a good line back when I analyzed it
in more depth about three years ago I
thought black was just in bad shape
roopd eight is what they usually try him
what is that I mean it's not even really
attacking c5 right I have to move like a
three
what would assume what is the point and
then the Queen will take okay okay okay
okay
hmm the Queen will take will will it to
take weather with a three queen c5
Knight b5 I am out 497 so that even
possible at the Queen okay and maybe he
can actually take g5 like a Queen takes
Knight be 525 yeah that's possible then
a3 was not the most logical never went I
mean I still don't believe this one bit
for black
that can never be enough compensation
am i threatening night b5 now night b5
Queen b6 Bishop c7 also a point Queen a6
and then I have discoveries okay Knight
b5 now I will win some material now but
I'm also just winning if I take a six
for example it's just strategically
completely busted a knight b5 should
just win now so let's do it
I mean it's a move that I will be not
very happy about if it doesn't
immediately win because just D takes c6
is game over
so Bishop c7 Queen a6 96 96 b5 Bishop b5
that's that's a full queen isn't that a
queen how is he not losing the Queen
that's funny yeah so yeah I think this
is not it's just not working you can
take on c4 which is a bit better but
still not good the best nine here's B
should be six okay takes rook da it has
been tried white plays this one and then
I don't quite remember actually I think
he six
some something like that okay night bt7
a3 b3 is probably not the best move
let's get a small of the better news
yeah Queen takes and now I can play
better than you forward if is not bad
so if for it is success losing that
hours which I mean what do you play her
and I don't really see a move
give no compensation
yeah this is just the Queen you can play
b5 and then the Queen is trapped again
yeah that's not a bad line against the
green felt I think it's mostly depends
on the evaluation of the visit Bishop e6
line here white I think does not have an
advantage every other line is at least
interesting okay yes
thanks for watching